wir haben als in ganz kurzer zeit bei
uns chaos 600 mit und österreich
viele menschen haben sich jetzt schon
aufgegeben und sehen keine perspektive
für sich und ihre kinder ist es ja so
dass in den abend und nachtstunden ist
zu konfliktsituationen in der familie
kommt dass es auch zu akuter
suizidalität keiner hat mehr ersparnisse
alles ist aufgebraucht jeder arbeitet
nicht nur noch mit verlusten
die zählen nicht wir sind nicht wichtig
und das mit uns passiert ist auch egal
natürlich spielt die rote jetzt nicht
mehr so eine große rolle weil die sorgen
in dem moment größer sind aber ich
versuche sie natürlich auch abzulenken
der musik die systemrelevanz absprechen
das ist problematisch weil also wenn was
nicht wichtig was dann ja vollkommen
schief gelaufen und bin ich sauer
letztens war die polizei da hat für
jeden 52 gekostet er ist da wo das leben
wenn die spiele tobt vertont hier mit
diese pflicht am ende eines tunnels ist
jetzt mal ziemlich weit entfernt
wir befinden uns zwar auf dem höhepunkt
der pandemie
wir sind noch lange nicht da wo wir hin
müssen und leider bekommen wir weiterhin
jeden tag sehr viele neue todesfälle
übermittelt
an vielen tagen sind es um die 1000
todesfälle der friedhof der frauen
kirchgemeinde meisten im februar dieses
jahres
seit monaten trägt bestatter jörg
schneider auf jeden tag die toten die
das saas kopf 2 virus gefördert hat zu
grabe oftmals ohne angehörige 84 jahre
alt geworden ist von nachbarn noch ins
krankenhaus eingeliefert wurden euro
dann ist sie verstorben
jetzt in der 102 eigentlich das problem
dass die noch von reform und dann werden
sie niedriges sehen also man kann eben
ins krankenhaus gehen nehmen wir
versuchen beim sterben nicht mehr der
hand halten und auch dieser abschied am
sorgt da sonst üblich ist wird auch
nicht mehr gemacht und damit ist diese
ganze einsamkeit schwer für die ideen
normalerweise trauern für die
hinterbliebenen zu diesem zeitpunkt
beklagt die republik fast 70.000 tote
die an oder mit corona gestorben sind
und meisten gehört lange zu den hotspots
in der halle des krematoriums stapeln
sich die särge akkordarbeit bei der
bewältigung der opfer
simulieren haben die meisten sind diese
schutzmaßnahmen nur wenige noch die die
pandemie erlaubt keine pause alle 45
minuten werden im krematorium meisten
corona tote verbrannt
[Musik]
in jedem sarg steckt ein schicksal
seit mehr als einem jahr befindet sich
die republik im kollektiven
ausnahmezustand
die dramatischen veränderungen könnten
nicht größer und der verursacher ein
virus nicht kleiner sein
die pandemie wird nicht nur für
politiker zur belastungsprobe
je länger es dauert kinder nicht mit
ihren freunden in ihrem gewohnten umfeld
in kita und schule zusammen kommen
können desto schwerer ist auch die last
im berliner stadtteil marzahn
hellersdorf spitzt sich die lage durch
die folgen des monatelangen lockt als
dramatisch zu
täglich versorgt pastor bernd siggelkow
leiter der hilfsorganisation arche
sozial schwache familien mit dem
nötigsten
die turnhalle gefüllt mit nahrungs
spenden also die kinder können ja gerade
nicht in der schule essen und auch nicht
in arche das heißt wir müssen die
familie die jetzt mehr belastet sind
natürlich auch unterstützen wir packen
schon immer ein bisschen vor damit wir
dann relativ schnell die tüten packen
können die familien bringen mit 270.000
einwohnern gehört marzahn hellersdorf zu
einem der größten stadtteile berlins
noch größer die wirtschaftlichen und
sozialen probleme die pandemie bringt
die menschen hier an die grenzen der
belastbarkeit am arsch auf deutsch
gesagt
heike bänsch mutter von fünf kindern ist
alleinerziehend normalerweise arbeitet
sie als verkäuferin
jetzt ist sie in kurzarbeit der druck
für die familie ist enorm glaubst du
denn wie lange das noch so besteht jetzt
dass du immer zu hause bleiben muss
das ist einfach vorbei ist für die
kinder ist es ja unser schlimmer finde
ich als ich mich für uns erwachsene seit
monaten dient das wohnzimmer als
klassenraum jeden mittag macht die
mutter mit lea und den geschwistern
hausaufgaben so weit es geht die ändern
sich ja immerhin die ganze mehr ist das
papier auch bei den großen jetzt wieder
das problem dass die rechtschreibung
sich ändert oder so wie sie die
matheaufgaben auch captain und sanitäter
also elternteil das kind gar nicht
vorbringen
doch ein paar jahre raus aus der schule
mehr als ein drittel aller kinder so die
psychologen leiden inzwischen unter den
folgen der pandemie
die mitarbeiter von krisen chat de
erhalten dramatische hilferufe der
jugendlichen seit mai letzten jahres
sind es jede woche rund 750 kinder
erreichen uns 24 7 per chat das heißt
wir sind auch in der nacht für sie da
und häufig ist es ja so dass in den
abend und nachtstunden es zu
konfliktsituationen in der familie kommt
dass es auch zu akuter suizidalität
kommt und da können wir einfach ganz
ganz schnell innerhalb weniger minuten
ein offenes ohr bieten die hilferufe der
jüngsten an die psychologisch geschulten
helfer treffen beinahe im minutentakt
ein
ich habe angst dass meine mutter mir weh
tut sie trinkt gerade wieder
manchmal wird sie laut und ich habe
angst das ist sehr nachvollziehbar
kinder werden häufiger zeuge von
häuslicher gewalt und es gibt ganz viele
themen die immer wieder aufkommen
insbesondere dass die halt gebenden
strukturen wegfallen also die schule der
freizeitverein die kita das sind alles
orte wo normalerweise die kinder und
jugendlichen gerade die die eh schon
belastet sind ganz viel halt und
unterstützung erfahren
wir sind im hinblick auf das pandemie
geschehen in einer situation die
wesentlich chromatischer ist als wir
alle uns das im letzten sommer hätten
vorstellen können
die deutsche volkswirtschaft ist im
letzten jahr um fünf prozent geschrumpft
es ist eine dramatische hohe zahl in der
zweitgrößten stadt deutschlands mussten
sich seit beginn der korona pandemie
fast 75.000 beschäftigte arbeitslos
melden
der lockte für viele menschen ein tiefer
fall in die pleite
schuldnerberater ralf berg leistet so
etwas wie erste hilfe und seine kunden
vor dem totalen bankrott zu bewahren
deutschland ist im augenblick knallrot
an zahlen
dh keiner hat mehr ersparnisse von
privatleuten und selbstständigen alles
ist aufgebraucht und jeder arbeitet
nicht nur noch mit verlusten
es gibt ein paar sieger der pandemie wie
in den lebensmitteleinzelhandel aber
alle anderen haben extreme probleme man
sieht es ja hier ist tot
es ist nichts los gar nichts sein
heutiger kunde ein fitnessstudio
betreiber in der hamburger innenstadt
mit biss fit wollte der mann eigentlich
5 jähriges feiern
die partylaune ist seit corona im keller
der zweite november der zweite lockt das
zweite mal muskels sein fitnessstudio
schließen auf die versprochenen november
hilfen wartet der trainer noch heute wir
haben einige kunden verloren die
ihrerseits vielleicht ihre arbeit
verloren haben
andererseits ist das home office thema
für uns ganz relevant weil die kunden
nicht mehr in der innenstadt sind sie
haben
also die größten kosten natürlich miete
personal und das gerätedesign sind
12.000 450 euro an kosten für den
dreifachen familienvater sind die
schuldigen an dem wirtschaftlichen
niedergang längst ausgemacht sein
vertrauen in die krisenmanager aus
berlin hat er verloren
im moment sehe ich das einfach hier
nicht mit augenmaß gehandelt wird und
inzwischen abgeschaltet unter anderem
einer und wir sorgen für die steuern den
mittelstand ist unsere tragende säule
und der it im moment vernichtet total
ja wir schauen wir das auch mit dem
vermieter sprechen
und ganz ganz wichtig dass wir diesen
weg gehen da werde ich mich auch jetzt
nächste woche sofort ansetzen und
aktivieren
davor hilfen bekommen nachher es ist ein
wettlauf mit der zeit
in einer halben stunde hat der
schuldnerberater schon seinen nächsten
termin
ich glaube er kommt über die pandemie
man muss jetzt schauen wie lange die
pandemie andauert das ist jetzt ganz
ganz wichtig also durch mietkürzung
vielleicht mit dem personal reden
vielleicht kriegen wir auch das dritte
hilfspaket jetzt mal ein bisschen
schneller auf dem weg werden wir
wahrscheinlich noch die zwei drei vier
fünf monate überbrücken können wir denen
der wirtschaftliche absturz er ist
branchenübergreifend denn die nächste
krise wartet nur ein paar kilometer
weiter auf deutschlands größter
vergnügungs und rotlicht meile der
reeperbahn im horizontalen gewerbe
herrscht tote hose und in den betten der
eros center läuft
monaten nichts mehr nach schätzungen
arbeiten mehr als 400.000 menschen in
der prostitution
eine von ihnen ist josefa mich mit den
menschen vergnügen werkzeug bald wenn
man das möchte mit den ganzen tools den
ich gerne arbeiter es gibt ja menschen
die lassen sich gerne fesseln die stehen
auf lieder oder auch seidentücher und
ganz ganz oft es sind relikte aus alten
tagen
normalerweise hat die sexarbeiterin bis
zu fünf kunden am tag
doch das infektionsschutzgesetz
verbietet ihr freier zu empfangen krone
hat mich eigentlich ziemlich hart
erwischt und das war schon sehr
unangenehm vor allem als mann oder auch
so gemerkt hat dass leute versuchen
diese situation auszunutzen im beruf
komplett zu verbieten
und auch im nachhinein damit zu bekommen
alle anderen dürfen schon wieder
arbeiten wir durften nicht arbeiten ja
mit den gesundheitsämtern konzepte
erarbeitet die wurden immer wieder
abgewehrt und das war schon irgendwie so
hat es den eindruck gemacht wir zählen
nicht wir sind nicht wichtig und das mit
uns passiert ist auch egal
wegen der pandemie musste josef an ihr
euch nun um schulen sozusagen um ein
wenig geld in die kasse zu kriegen dreht
die 34-jährige nun videos sex gibt es
jetzt nur noch 2.0
es ist der einzige höhepunkt ihres tages
[Musik]
weiterhelfen wird es dem rotlicht wohl
nur wenn politiker grünes licht zur
wiedereröffnung geben nach offiziellen
angaben setzt die prostitution branche
jedes jahr rund sechs milliarden euro um
die eigentliche summe dürfte wesentlich
höher sein
auch das ist ein wichtiger
wirtschaftszweig für die republik
das ist jetzt nicht ganz furchtbar zu
sehen dass schotten dicht sind die
niemand ist obwohl hier immer was los
ist immer betrieb ist ist ganz
unangenehm jetzt das sehen ist das
manchmal so nah führt wie bedroht also
eigentlich auch unsere branche aussieht
und wenn das hier ausstirbt das wäre
fatal
ohne krone arbeiten hier rund 250
sexarbeiterinnen viele von ihnen
bekommen nun transferleistungen
sie haben sich alle mühe gegeben die
haben das konzept dass jede konzept ja
auch gefolgt genau wie die hier die
gastronomiebetriebe die die feier musste
ja auch immer ihre daten lassen
die laufhäuser sie laufen einfach nicht
mehr
zurück in die hauptstadt berlin ist die
zweite heimat von ekrem bora alias
rapper eko fresh der deutsch-türke
spielt sozusagen in der oberliga des hip
hops trotzdem trifft auch in corona es
ist wichtiger denn je in dieser zeit die
leute ein bisschen abzulenken
man denkt ja auch dass gerade jeder voll
auf mucke steht und so weiter das ist
gar nicht so ist nicht so dass alle
streams so gehen im gegenteil die
streams sind eher rückläufig bei den
meisten ja dass das bemühen sich daran
oder das ja klar ich mir so dass diese
stellen wo man so gesellschaftlich wird
einfach nur wo viele zusammensitzen
irgendwelchen cafés oder discos das gibt
es halt nicht mehr
eko fresh karriere hat in kreuzberg
begonnen
noch immer wird der selbst ernannte
könig von deutschland hier gefeiert
natürlich corona konform sind unser held
für den besten gibt es nur das beste
essen
ja hallo spencer türkische erstmals es
so also jetzt vielleicht nicht bei mama
gibt so sondern draußen gegessen wird im
auto trotz promi-status eco hält sich
gewissenhaft an die kone regeln aus
gutem grund
ich bin immer stellvertretend für alle
türken sozusagen oder deutsch türken ja
wenn ich was falsch machen ist das für
alle helfer ich bin irgendwas richtig
mies falsch liegen da wird man ja also
haben wir gewusst die sind alle so und
so
das heißt ich habe doch sowieso in mir
drinnen immer aufzupassen termin beim
haus und hof produzenten in berlin mitte
im gegensatz zu anderen künstlern geht
es dem deutsch rapper noch
verhältnismäßig gut
eco steckt gerade mitten in der
produktion fürs neue album ein jahr ohne
konzerte auftritte und festivals
der umsatz in deutschland eventbranche
ist wegen corona um mehr als 70 prozent
eingebrochen
künstler richtig pleite gehen und wie
viel schaffende künstler die eigentlich
leben von live konzerten so wir sind
alle die sind alle durch die können
nicht mehr
wenn du da jetzt über musik spricht und
der musik die systemrelevanz absprechen
das ist das live problematisch weil
sowohl musik als auch bei sich die
schauspielerei sind sachen was wir uns
tagtäglich reinziehen eigentlich das was
wir uns nur ein ziel auf dem handy vor
allen dingen lockt auch wenn jetzt
gerade alle zu hause sind also wenn was
nicht wichtig ist was dann
[Musik]
aha kunst ist also nicht systemrelevant
doch im job down haben wir uns denn am
wegewart naja wir warten auf den
paketlieferung bis im home office und
kinder bei serien an und ist wie das in
jeder gruppe sind sie fürs und zwar aber
weil es um die gesundheit geht kann man
sie gerade leider nicht so richtig in
die welt der titanic schnitte sondern
gesehen da geht der webcam girl rock sie
war das home office auf forscher der
ständige arbeitsplatz die gelernte
zahnarzthelferin regelt sich gegen
entgelt hüllenlos vor der kamera zu
sehen über einen videochat doch seit
ausbruch der pandemie muss roxy immer
häufiger als seelendoktor einspringen
ihre traummaße sind da nicht mehr so
gefragt dass die angst vorm alleinsein
haben dass man besuchen sie einen nach
dem chat und natürlich auch vor allen
dingen die ängste wie sieht die zukunft
aus
kann ich mein restaurant halten kann ich
mein klub behalten kann ich meine
mitarbeiter bezahlen und natürlich
spielt die rote jetzt nicht mehr so eine
große rolle weil halt die sorgen in dem
moment größer sind aber ich versuche sie
natürlich auch abzulenken also versucht
dann in dem moment in freude zu bereiten
mich zu zeigen ihre wünsche in meinen
augen zu erfüllen und dass sie hat
trotzdem irgendwo spaß an
für die meisten kunden ist roxy in den
zeiten des lok downs die einzige
bezugsperson zur außenwelt da stört auch
nicht die distanz durch den fernseher
die regelmäßigen video treffs mit roxy
gehören für patrick zu den highlights im
ansonsten trüben corona alltag der 32
jährige lkw fahrer aus hellersdorf wird
ab dem ersten mai seinen job verlieren
die firma hat keine aufträge mehr für
ihn sogar zweimal im monat für mich ist
auf jeden fall wichtig mit jemandem zu
reden darüber der mir vertraut
rüberkommen in der heutigen zeit ist dem
teils oder muss man sich gegenseitig
helfen da kann man nicht als
alleinstehender durch die welt ziehen
man merkt er selber auch das nicht mehr
so einfach ist also von daher finde ich
ja doch ganz so dass die roxy mir auch
hierzu gehört mir gesehen hinweise oder
tipps gibt wie man sich zu verhalten hat
oder wie man sich doch ein bisschen
ablenkt also die machte dafür schon
verdammt gut zu hause ich bin zu hause
arbeiten musste man keine komplimente
schön unterricht dann gefällt mir wird
liebt wenn du schon morgen gerade vorbei
wäre
damit sich die leute auch wieder ein
bisschen entspannen und wir alle wie
auch miteinander umgehen können und uns
doch mal wieder sehen können dass er hat
doch wird findet mit der freundschaft zu
tun die draußen sitzen mal also das werk
in ordentliches leben meiner hinsicht
debatte in deutschland geht immer über
die bestellmenge aber die wahrheit es
auch dass der impfstoff weltweit gerade
ein knappes gut ist
essen altendorf seit corona passiert vor
dem fenster von rentnerin ingrid
kardinal kaum noch etwas
etwas seltener geworden ganz
auszuschließen und guckt man auch schon
mal die 62-jährige ist diabetikerin und
gehört zur risikogruppe
seit tagen schon versucht ingrid
kardinal informationen über einen
möglichen impftermin zu bekommen
doch bisher war die 116 117 immer
besetzt diesmal hat sie etwas mehr glück
wünsche ich ihnen auch dankeschön mit
den impfungen hatte ich genauso ein witz
wie die meisten deutschen jetzt erstmal
hier die darauf warten dass er da zu
wenig haben
und wenn ich dann sogar amerika hat
schon mehr israel ja vielleicht könnte
ich da hin wenn ich da an dahinter wenn
ich wahrscheinlich eher wie im spiel in
deutschland also das kann ich nicht
sagen natürlich vollkommen schief
gelaufen und darüber bin ich auch bei
der durchsetzung der korona maßnahmen
traut die rentnerin den behörden nicht
so recht über den weg
so schaut frau kardinal lieber selber
nach dem rechten
einsatz auf dem benachbarten
fußballplatz gelbe karten gibt es bei
der 62 jährigen nicht hier wird direkt
rot gezeigt und wir waren irgendwann
zaun kletterten auf das gelände
eindringen nennt man das
hausfriedensbruch packt zusammen und
runter letztens war die polizei da hat
für jeden 250 gekostet ich weiß nicht ob
wir auch zu dem club gehören wollte die
zahlen immer gleich die nächste station
auf ingrid kardinal streife kult kiosken
tägliches corona update mit der kids
legende seit über 40 jahren dient der
laden als die informationsquelle für
alle essen sogar besser muss ich sagen
aber wichtige geschäft ist ja für mich
die sportartikel oder tut sich ja nichts
mehr
sie macht es gut ich hoffe ich
sportartikel pokale und anderen nippes
bei willy göken gibt es einfach alles
vokal geschäft ist eine gute sache
wenn die saison wieder da ist nur wir
haben im moment leider schon fast kaum
betrieb nur entsteht rum und ist ganz
staub nutzen
der 82-jährige ein grundes seinerzeit
die pandemie ist längst nicht das
schlimmste was der erlebt hat in einer
art dauer kriegszustand befinden sich
auch die gegner der korona maßnahmen
allwöchentliche autokorso in berlin
charlottenburg wo das virus ja aber ich
glaube nicht an diese über sterblichkeit
die prognostizierten verbreitet
maximal vorgehen was sie bei claudia
corona
ob impfgegner anhänger von
verschwörungstheorien oder einfach
normale kritiker der korona politik die
ständig wechselnden maßnahmen erhitzen
die gemüter immer mehr
und während man in charlottenburg noch
mit sirenen und ps gegen die
beschränkungen trust hat sich ein
stadtteil weiter eine zweite front
aufgetan die schwerpunktkontrolle des
ordnungsamtes berlin mitte im einsatz
gegen masken muffel laut
infektionsschutz verordnung muss man
sich auf diese einkaufsstraße in moabit
bedeckt halten
auch in den geschäften wird kontrolliert
also das wichtigste was ich jetzt aber
achte ist natürlich die mund nasen
bedeckung und dass er auch die maximale
anzahl an kunden nicht übertroffen wird
alles sehr sehr gut
es ist das ist jetzt wenig hier gerade
brille los und alle diejenigen die die
maske jetzt zur zeit auf fragen sollen
dann im wasser auf 50 euro strafe wäre
die maske scheut cash oder per karte der
einsatzleiter kennt kein pardon
doch der widerstand des gegners ist
größer als erwartet
ich kann ihnen auch einfach waren
geldangebot machen 755 euro direkt vor
ort zahlen waren oder mit karte
das wollen wir gehen dahin hängen sie
mir jetzt sofort gültig werde jetzt mit
ihnen nicht dahin ja das ist er dann was
ist denn das und werkstatt sie können
sich ja gerne dazu äußern sachlich ich
möchte mich ein ich hab keine lust ins
gespräch ich bin hier ganz normal
gelaufen familiäre personalien
aushändigen
aber dann war dass sie sich noch einmal
der euro dann der erste fluchtversuch
doch die abwehr steht kurze zeit scheint
der kontrollierte einsicht zu zeigen
doch dann mit einem geschickten rechts
links manöver gelingt dem jungen mann
der durchbruch
somit entzieht er sich einer saftigen
geldstrafe und einer überprüfung durch
die polizei
szenen aus dem corona alltag
jetzt unser weg wir werden jetzt nicht
mehr hinterher rennt hätte man jetzt
direkt gekriegt werden ursache aber
glück in einer stunde endet die einheit
22 verstöße gegen die masken pflicht
8100 euro strafe dann wird es kurzzeitig
unübersichtlich verstoß gegen die masken
pflicht alkohol im freien und und und
eine gruppe männer zeigt sich abstands
und anstandslos und wenig
kooperationsbereit
das problem keiner kann sich so richtig
ausweisen
die männer müssen erst ihre papiere
heranschaffen von wo auch immer
was sagen sie zu den maßnahmen hier was
sagen sie maßnahmen wussten sie was also
mit der maske wusste ich ja dass man
nicht draußen trinken kann das wusste
ich nicht wo kommen sie her ich aus
meine mutter dann geht es für die
einheit weiter in die berliner nacht
alles zum schutz für die bevölkerung
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass wir
in dieser saison noch mal volle stadien
abend werden dass geisterspiele denkbar
sind ist etwas was die liga im moment
mit den ländern erörtert
seit einem jahr muss die bundesliga in
nahezu leeren stadien spielen für hart
gesottene fans wie willi blenkers
schlimmer als der abstieg des eigenen
vereins keiner geht keiner springt ja
vor ein auto ist einfach traurig dass
man das nicht sehen kann dass man hat
nicht führen kann
diese dieses knistern in der luft wenn
schalke spiel hat geisterspiele chaos im
verein und tabellenletzter als schalke
fan hat man es gerade nicht leicht
einschalte bedeutet für mich ein
großteil meines lebens ist begleitet
mich seit 1969 weil eine gute ehe ist
genau wie eine gute liebe zum verein
weil wenn alle glücklich gerade frisch
verliebt haben keine probleme
aber wenn mal wieder der alltag kommt
wenn du denn das wäre wenn die ersten
niederschläge kommen wenn die ersten
rückschläge da sind die ersten probleme
da will dann muss man zusammenstehen der
62 jährige wird von allen nur trompeten
willi genannt sein ritual vor jedem
heimspiel
[Musik]
apa
warum
dann geht es wieder nach hause heimspiel
gucken nicht im stadion aber im trauten
heim schalke gegen leipzig
[Musik]
die antiken dorf nord gegen marl sinsen
oder was also wird sozusagen
geisterspiele den flush ich sage mal
kleiner haufen scheiße ist immer noch
scheiße aber ganz ausfallen lassen dass
er ganz fatal
doch dann verliert der westen gegen den
osten drei zu eins für leipzig es ist
kein guter tag für schalke für ela und
erdal ist es jedoch der schönste wenige
kilometer weiter vom stadion entfernt
traut sich das paar trotz pandemie im
standesamt gelsenkirchen
erlaubt sind im saal nur der gemeinsame
sohn und ihr fotograf
das paar hatte eine riesige party
geplant doch das virus hat wieder mal
einen strich durch die rechnung gemacht
[Musik]
glückwünsche der wenigen gäste mit maske
und dem nötigen abstand liebe in zeiten
der pandemie
zumindest dieser tag ein gutes ende
[Musik]